when I got the call to play LeBron
James's mother I was static to play a
woman that is so instrumental in this
man's light it's such an honor what's
important is that when you look back did
you make the time you had together count
it's been a great experience playing
LeBron James A lot of people drew about
this opportunity it's bigger than
basketball it's about a Brotherhood it's
about family it's about love my baby's a
celebrity my squad my squad seemed like
they'll be friends forever I feel like
he's almost like the Father Figure to
all of us I don't know what it is but
y'all gonna do something special
together
it was really important for us to
celebrate the community of Akron due by
the example that LeBron has set putting
Akron on the map became a responsibility
for us it's more than basketball so many
great things that can happen when you
come together as one
it's the work of love it's the work of
care it's the work of motivation the
biggest superheroes are the ones that
are living among us raising up
tomorrow's leaders
[Music]